o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark e
sejam muito bem vindos à noite do fim de
ano bom que vai acontecer hoje é o
quinto aos tempos eu vi um vídeo que eu
cortei para caraças que é do canal e
nook wisco acho que assim basicamente
hitler league of legends e o tipo parte
mais rico aquela cena e o jogo por fazer
é mais ou menos a mesma coisa vai eu vou
copiar mesmo agora vamos ter outra
rodada de mais que fazer do jogo quer
que este ano aqui e falei que eu vou
fazer você não ficou bem claro vou fazer
o meu pelo menos aguentar jogar logo
nessa borracha e deixa o peão que só
você está f
o que a oposição faça uma discussão
porque eu não fiz
apesar do vídeo também não posso apontar
a câmera sempre foi esse o que é normal
que esteja a falar com as pessoas para
que que acho que tenho que ficar aqui na
imitação trintas com isso é ponto este
esforço é para chegar logo terceiro fica
que já não vêm cá cara aí eu pensei em
fita cola hora para jogar muito para não
chover muito para servir para o custo do
urubu haja 6 turbo custo justo é minha
se termine esse mesmo golpe em golpe que
compreendamos porque joga futebol afã e
pentear desceu é elvis e sabe que é
médico
esta banda é médico e deputado em long
beach com os nomes das obras também
jogou muitos garotos investigava está
frito comigo tentou brincar cara compra
botas' calçada show vai morrer mas
morrer após morrer mas não cantou mas
não crê em um jogo fácil neste jogo o
piloto behrs tudo isto não é para jogar
ao jogador profissional nunca foram
acusados esta usa raiva
outras duas horas fortes tem que estar
ligado ao pcp que o psd defina qual os
cazaques só uma vez só entrou em campo
ele por telefone
eu fui do tipo olha mas tudo mais
gallows o windows entrega simbólica do
tua mãe que estava encostada à cabeça
ok outro vício julgar o dólar miguel
monteiro girl montanha sério para 30.150
por incapacidade de o filho perto
alimentos de outras pessoas que caminham
por ele não toca o curso não toca à
província o que a gente quer as pessoas
aí essa doce béchir ano em mim pode
fazer caixa e as pessoas que o fida isso
não é desculpa seu poder até do que a
senhora que nesta hora varia muito para
porto alegre porque agora tudo chateado
com o valor pode tomar o poder logo eu
acho que vamos ter aqui muitos problemas
nesta que é isso aqui que tira a itaqui
uma ficha solta desculpa porque não joga
água pesada mais confortável
esta foi a quarta vez que o campeão
olha só comentam meu cotovelo a jogar
outra vez meu
ae